and this ties in with an issue that we
were talking about yesterday i have to
revisit it
because i got in so much trouble for my
views and i didn't even get in trouble
with the left i got in trouble really
with conservatives who are who think
that i'm too conservative or something
this issue of of kicking out andrew
jackson from the 20
bill and putting harriet tubman on there
i
saw a lot of conservatives yesterday who
were tweeting out
as if to win the applause of the left
and they were saying
listen leftists i haven't seen a single
conservative
who isn't totally on board with kicking
out andrew jackson
and putting harriet tubman on the 20.
please show me the one conservative okay
here it i'm the one conservative
you found me i guess you guys weren't
weren't looking too hard because here i
am
and i don't think it's just me by the
way i think a lot of americans
don't want to kick andrew jackson off
the 20 bill
they don't want to castigate jackson and
say he was an awful rotten terrible
person
and jackson really is just he's just an
easy target
but this this campaign which comes from
the 1776 project
and affiliated groups seeks to
overturn all of our venerated forebears
it's not just going to stop at jackson
it's going to go to jefferson and
washington and lincoln it already is
they're already toppling statues of
those guys
i think there are a lot of americans who
feel that way and i i understand
that there are many conservatives who
really want to prove to the left that
they're not racist but i
i have to promise you that
the left already thinks you're a racist
and they also don't care
whether or not you're a racist if you
are
what is racism racism is the unjust
discrimination against people
and antagonism of people on the basis of
their race it is wrong because it is an
offense against human dignity
that's it if you're not that then don't
worry about it you don't need to prove
anything to the left you won't be able
to prove anything to the left it's very
pitiful to try to prove these things to
the left
they are not going to start liking you
because you're saying mean things about
andrew jackson
they don't like you okay sorry
pretending to love the harriet tubman 20
bill is not going to save you from the
gulags
be they digital or otherwise it's just
so lame this is why we lose every
cultural issue
this is it guys i you know when we look
back
on all the crazy politically correct
cultural changes that have happened
we say why didn't conservatives stand up
i mean let's use the
gendered bathrooms for a second the you
know boys can use the girls room or
whatever
we said what how on earth do we get to
this place why didn't we stand up
well the reason that we got to this
place is because every
time the issue was actually hot actually
every time it was actually happening
conservatives who wanted to go along to
get along said oh who cares it's not a
big deal
they did they did it even with the
bathrooms there were many conservatives
who said oh it does who cares
it affects very few people let's it's
fine if some if some boys are confused
and think they're girls let's just it's
fine let's not
i don't want people to think i'm a bigot
or this phobe or that phobe so let's
let's just not touch it we're going to
redefine marriage well let's i don't
want people to think i'm a bigot of some
so let's just
let's not touch it we're going to
redefine
whole norms in society let's not touch
it we're going to institute new
legal racial discrimination in the form
of affirmative action well let's i don't
want to
who cares it's not a big deal it only
affects a few slots at a university it
only affects a few jobs please
let's let's go along to get along this
is the same thing guys
do not do not tell me who cares
when we say that these cultural issues
don't matter like the harriet tubman 20
bill doesn't matter we give away
the whole game when we say oh forget
about that let's just talk about the
economy
the cultural issues not only do they not
not matter the cultural issues pretty
much are the only thing that matters
what profited if a nation
to have gdp through the roof
but to lose its whole culture that's
not that's not what matters and
conservatives need to shake themselves
out of this very silly idea
that all that matters is tax cuts and
bumping up gdp a little bit so that jeff
bezos can buy a new yacht
that's not what matters you know what
matters preserving our traditions
preserving our love of country
preserving our local communities
preserving our venerated figures and
forebears
and rituals that's what matters and it'd
be nice to get low taxes too
but that is going to come downstream
okay the the economic policy is going to
come downstream
of that cultural policy
when you say it doesn't matter who cares
20 bill doesn't matter well
you know it matters to me it matters i
think to a great number of conservatives
so good if it doesn't matter then let it
go
right if it doesn't really matter then
fine then we won't change it
because you're you're the one who wants
to change it leftist
and i'm the one who doesn't want to
change it and you say it doesn't matter
and no one cares and i say i care
so good let it go oh they're not going
to let it go though because they do
care and they care for a reason because
they know that the framing of
our nation in the minds of its citizens
is the whole game it will utterly
transform the politics that's why joe
biden is so eager
to cancel the 1776 commission and to
castigate it as offensive
offensive to to love your country
that will not get us unity
but the left of course does not want
unity i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the michael knowles show to check out
the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you